while bandana clad millennials cower at
home
in fear our 74 year old
fast food chomping physical exercise
issuing president
just beat the china virus in three days
he has now
been discharged from walter reed medical
center he has returned
to the white house he has walked out
onto that
front portico of the white house to show
everybody that he is fit as a fiddle
that he is strong he took his mask off
while he was far away from people just
to show everyone he was doing all right
and the mainstream media could not be
more upset
this is awesome here we go a very
different
takes it off an incorrect message and
you see him here um he takes it off
and he's getting ready for his pictures
the flags flank him
right caitlyn this is what he did this
is the moment this is what he produced
it for he wants the image to be
i'm strong this virus is nothing
just tweet today feeling better than i
did 20 years ago don't be afraid of kova
don't let it dominate your life
there he is this is the image he wants
yeah and let us hear us now that the
president is on steroids
and a drug that fewer than 10 people
outside of clinical trials have gotten
inside the united states to deal with
coronavirus
he had a level of treatment and a level
of care that most americans would not
get
don't sound so happy about it is the
president of the united states obviously
everyone expects that
but what the president is portraying by
taking his mask off
when he gets back to the truman balcony
to give this
this grand return to the white house is
that everything is fine and as he said
don't let coronavirus control your life
but that is very much still a president
who has coronavirus
yeah it is and he's not letting it
control his life and he's projecting
strength and telling people not to be
afraid
as he should sorry ghouls i'm sorry
that the president has recovered and
that's so hard for you sorry that the
president is telling
not just the american people but the
whole world that he's strong and he's
not going to let this thing
destroy him i know you thought you had
him but you didn't
and not only was that scene important to
emerge from the balcony take the mask
off
project strength but he explained
exactly
why he did it for all those cowards and
fear mongers
in the mainstream media who just
couldn't get it
i learned so much about coronavirus
and one thing that's for certain don't
let it
dominate you don't be afraid of it
you're going to beat it we have the best
medical equipment we have the best
medicines
all developed recently and you're going
to beat it i went i didn't feel so good
and two days ago i could have left two
days ago two days ago i felt great like
better than i have in a long time i said
just recently
better than 20 years ago don't let it
dominate don't let it take over your
lives
don't let that happen we have the
greatest country in the world
we're going back we're going back to
work we're going to be out front
as your leader i had to do that i knew
there's danger to it but i had to do it
i stood out front i led nobody that's a
leader
would not do what i did and i know
there's a risk there's a danger but
that's okay
and now i'm better and maybe i'm immune
i don't know
but don't let it dominate your lives get
out there
be careful we have the best medicines in
the world
go on out there do not be afraid do not
live your lives in fear
all the mainstream media don't want to
hear that they do want you to cower in
fear those are two different views
of the country those are two different
views of politics those are two
different views
of life we will take the trump view we
will
encourage you because there's a whole
lot of reason to be encouraged i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from connor adams
connor says even the virus chooses trump
over biden that's true
and there's a lot of evidence by the way
that more and more people around this
country
are choosing trump over biden despite
what some of the polls say and actually
if you look a little more closely into
those polls they actually tell that
story we will
go through all of it you know you've got
to not just
read the polls you've got to listen to
what people in the country
are saying because of course some
pollster calls you some stranger says
are you going to vote for the mango
mussolini that everyone's been telling
us as hitler for the last four years
you're probably not going to be willing
to do that you've got to listen very
carefully
and one of the best ways to listen
carefully is to use raycon
wireless earbuds using a pair of premium
wireless earbuds
it is the best way to listen to anything
especially
if you can get them at less than half
the price of the other guys
which is why you got to check out raycon
raycon's newest model
the everyday e25 earbuds are their best
ones yet
six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing
more bass and more compact design and
noise isolating fit raycon earbuds they
are stylish
they are discreet no dangling wires or
stems
i have another pair of wireless earbuds
as well and sometimes i'll switch them
on off just to try just to see what it's
like
the raycon are better okay and i think
we all know what the other ones are the
raycon are better they are that's just
the way it is
give them a try raycon has a 45 day free
return policy
so you can make sure they are the
wireless earbuds that are for
you total game changer and right now for
a limited time
you get fifteen percent of your order at
buy recon dot com slash knowles k
wlas that is by raycon dot com slash
knowles
for a special 15 discount on raikon
wireless earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal is running you're you're going to
be like me you can try them out you can
compare them to the other one i'm
telling you
the raycon ones are going to be better
buy raycon dot com slash knowles can it
w-l-e-s
trump says don't be afraid the media say
do be afraid jake tapper on cnn
i think he typified his entire
profession when he watched that scene of
president trump
when he listened to him say do not be
afraid and he
couldn't have been angrier president
trump wrote on twitter
don't be afraid of covid don't let it
dominate your life
almost 210 000 americans are
dead from this disease meaning hundreds
of thousands of people
in this country are mourning or we just
reached we look at that we just reached
210 000
uh since i've been on air 210 000
americans dead
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
americans mourning them
7.4 million americans uh have contracted
the disease many of them are going to
have health problems for the rest of
their life
for president trump who gets the best
medical care of anybody in the world to
say
don't be afraid of covid don't let it
dominate your life there are
children who don't have parents now
because of this virus
don't let it dominate your life i mean
jake this is this is so disrespectful
i'm not even sure i can i can speak
about this in some sort of
uh cogent way here it is disrespectful
this segment on jake tapper's show is
very
very very disrespectful nothing trump
said is disrespectful
it's it's amazing if president trump
were a democrat and he gave this speech
they'd be hailing it as the greatest
speech since fdr
said that there is nothing to fear but
fear itself should fdr not have said
that fdr should have come out and said
in the depths of the depression there is
a lot to fear you got to be afraid
man people are losing their whole
livelihoods people are killing
themselves
children don't have parents now be
afraid be very very
afraid that's what the media want to
tell you
how ghoulish is it that cnn has a clock
of people who die
from coronavirus did you see jake tapper
there that hack
did you see what he said sitting there
the president is
he's recovered and he's strong and but
people are dying oh look haha look yes
210 000 people now yes
be afraid don't look so happy jake don't
look so happy
i was speaking yesterday when i was
hosting ben's show to dr marty mccary
i said what are we going to make of this
in light of other epidemics and he said
well it's very selective how the
mainstream media are talking about this
because of course what was just a few
years ago we had almost 80
000 deaths from the seasonal flu should
the president come out and say
be afraid of the flu be very afraid stay
at home because of the flu
children don't have parents because of
the flu of course that's true
should we should we fearmonger over that
no
no you cannot live in fear what the
media are trying to say that trump said
is that the disease poses no danger at
all
that isn't what he said that isn't what
we conservatives are saying either i
made this point
yesterday we're not saying don't
be afraid because the virus can't infect
you
or because there won't be negative
consequences from the virus
we're saying don't be afraid because we
have to live our lives
this get does get i suppose to a bottom
religious difference
which is that if you are a christian
at least a christian i suppose if you're
religious in other ways as well
or you're an adherent to other religions
too you'd
often you don't believe that this is all
there is
i'm not no expert on judaism in islam
but i think that they have views
that are a little bit bigger than this
material world certainly christians do
this isn't the end of the story there
are more important things
to life than than just our physical
selves
okay there are more important by the way
even if you're just a
total stone cold atheist let's say
you're just a stoic
let's say that you you're not focused on
the
the life after death still
you can have courage still you can say
i'm being confronted with this challenge
and i'm going to face it head-on like a
man with toughness
we used to say that in this country and
then the whiny
sniveling mainstream media come out and
tell us to be afraid how dare they
how dare they do that it's a horrible
thing to do terrible way to tell people
to live their lives and by the way jake
tapper
wasn't incredibly the most hysterical
person on this yesterday
that honor went to the cbs a white house
correspondent
who wished that he were in north korea
because he would feel safer
you know safety at the white house
compared to other places around the
world
is i think a little bit higher for most
journalists i think a lot of journalists
when they go north korea or other
tyrannical regimes
they're in much greater danger and
obviously there are dangers in this
country one of which is distracted
driving it's a serious problem on our
roadways that leads to the deaths of
thousands of people and injuries
in the hundreds of thousands each year
so when you take your eyes and your
focus off the road even for just a
second
it can be deadly not just for you but
for other drivers pedestrians and
bicyclists sadly many americans are
using their cell phones while driving
whether it's texting checking emails
scrolling media feeds or any other form
of distraction
drivers are putting themselves and
others around them at greater risk which
is why it's important to know
that 48 states ban texting and driving
also
also 21 states prohibit all drivers from
using cell phones while driving
distracted drivers are not only putting
people at risk
they're also breaking the law it's
dangerous to use your cell phone behind
the wheel
that's why law enforcement officers
write tickets and enforce
hands-free and anti-texting and driving
laws you gotta when you are driving you
got to put down your phone
you've got to keep your hands on the
wheel you've got to keep your eyes
on the road and your mind on the task of
driving you drive
you text you pay brought to you by nitza
that may have been my smoothest
transition i've ever had even i lost oh
my gosh we're talking about the
journalist and then we're in
this journalist at cbs news
uh he's the he's the white house guy
there he tweets that quote i felt safer
reporting in north korea than i
currently do reporting at the white
house this is just crazy this is in fact
crazy this statement is crazy
maybe this journalist felt safer in
north korea
because he had a little bit more in
common ideologically with the government
of north korea than he does
with the government of the united states
but in reality he certainly was not
safer
it's it's this attempt
to make you believe that a disease where
you have a greater than 99 chance of
survival
is worse than the black death worse than
the bubonic plague
why are they trying to do this to keep
you from going to work
to keep you from going out to keep the
economy depressed
major prominent leftists told us before
the disease
and they told us that they were hoping
for a recession
because even though it would hurt people
it would
hurt trump's chances of winning
re-election bill maher came out and said
explicitly
on television there there is a huge
political incentive for the left
to keep you afraid but leaders don't do
that it's a very
very terrible thing to do to make people
be afraid
courage courage is a virtue
courage is actually a prerequisite
virtue
you you need courage to enact all of the
other virtues
and that's what the president is saying
and we need to see that this is why the
the left has never understood
strength peace through strength they
never understood reagan they never
understood trump on this point
in order to have peace you need to
project
strength because that deters aggression
trump was doing that explicitly the
other night or last night rather at the
white house
but in anything in life if you come off
strong
then you will not hopefully as much
need to use force you will not invite
aggression strength is a good thing
i i said yesterday on the show i said
that the
liberals are misunderstanding us because
they think that we're not wearing the
masks or whatever not wearing the masks
all the time alone
in our cars or we're not in favor of all
these draconian lockdown measures
because we think we can never get the
virus when in fact we oppose all those
things
because we know that we're all going to
get the virus because this new virus
is here to stay and if we don't get it
now we'll get it later
and if we don't get it later we'll get
it even later than that
but it is out there it's around it's
going to come back well the world health
organization
seems to be backing up my point
the world health organization said on
monday that its best estimates indicate
that up to 10 percent of the global
population
has already been infected with covid19
already
the virus has only existed for what
eight or nine months
and already 10 of earth has gotten it
we quoted other doctors yesterday an
expert from colombia who told npr that
in in studies the masks fail not even
necessarily because the masks themselves
but because people don't use them
correctly and they touch their face and
they move it all over themselves
dr fauci says the vaccine in a perfect
world is going to give us
hurt immunity but we don't live in a
perfect world and
some people aren't going to get it so
then we're not going to get hurt
immunity
so the virus believe it or not there is
a limit to politics
and the virus cannot be abolished
through
a really smart social policy
the virus is here and either we can live
the rest of our lives in fear
or we can man up and deal with it
the left doesn't want to do that the
left really believes there's no limit to
politics
the left really believes this is
this is a matter of life and death truly
a matter of life and death for all of us
and they can save the whole world if we
just follow their policies this is not
just true of the
elite politicians who occupy the senate
or or when democrats win occupy the
white house or occupy the bureaucracy
this is true all the way down the line
all the way to elementary school
teachers
middle school teachers there's a teacher
in seattle our pal jason rants up in
seattle found this one
there's a teacher up in seattle who
kicked
a child out of her classroom now her
virtual classroom because they don't
have
real classrooms kicked the kid out for
saying that he admires donald trump the
teacher
was in a in a group chat with with his
students
and he said who is a role model who is
someone that you want to follow
and the kid said quote is a 10 year old
kid in tacoma
i admire donald j trump because he is
making america great again
and because he's the best president the
united states could ever ever have
and he built the wall so terrorists
couldn't come into the u.s trump is the
best person in the world
and that's why i admire him
this teacher kicked the child
out of the classroom for saying he
admires the president
the president who now just recovered
from the coronavirus and showed showed
us all strength
the teacher once the teacher kicked the
kid out the the kid's mother who was
looking over and seeing the screen
started to record it listen to this
whiny morally idiotic teacher
positive things and role models that we
should admire
again the example that was shared in the
chat
which i went ahead and erased for us was
not appropriate right
especially as that individual has
created so much division and hatred
between people
and specifically um spoken hatred to
many different individuals okay so
i do apologize for kicking out of the
conference as i went ahead and adjusted
our settings
but the settings should be adjusted now
um
the chat should be locked for today just
because i i realized that maybe that
question
wasn't clear enough um so we'll go ahead
and
skip on that for today okay again
um that individual has spoken
hate to many individuals
and i don't think is
an appropriate example for a role model
um
who did you say donald j trump and this
teacher
this little wuss this this sniveling
little
teacher comes out and kicks the kid out
and he wouldn't even accept
responsibility for it
he says well and i went in and i
adjusted the settings and i'm sorry if
the student got kicked out or i adjusted
the settings and you can't say that you
like the president he's a mean guy he
hate the president
this is obviously a teacher who does not
understand the virtues
of courage the virtues of strength the
virtue of
manliness harvey mansfield professor at
harvard
wrote a great book called manliness a
number of years ago about this
virtue the word virtue by the way
relates to manliness it comes from
the latin word veer which means man veer
to
manliness but now we're told in our
culture that manliness is toxic
and we all need to be effeminate
and when when women are effeminate
that's a perfectly fine thing
but when men are it's not a fine thing
when
you know there's a difference in words
you say womanly
to refer to a woman and you say
woman-ish to refer
to a man who is being effeminate what's
the difference
one is positive one is negative one is
proper
the other is bizarre off-kilter and
that's what we're seeing here
we're being told that that manliness
itself
is toxic so is it any surprise that the
media react negatively
when the president shows some strength
but it turns out all those people are
completely wrong
it is important particularly in times of
trial particularly in times of danger
to show some strength and some duty and
some responsibility i'm sure trump
wanted nothing more than to go lie down
in the east wing of the white house
and fluff up a pillow and relax because
i'm sure he's not feeling very well
right now
but he came out anyway
because that is his responsibility
and sniveling teachers in the mainstream
media don't get it
some people are openly calling for his
death
they're going out on the internet they
are these are sometimes
even even people who are going out into
the streets as well but then they take
to the internet
and they call for the president's death
and that is not a good use of the
internet when you're on the internet you
should instead use it to buy auto parts
at rockauto.com now look me i obviously
don't know very much about cars so when
i go into a brick and mortar store what
happens
i don't know anything about the parts
that i need they don't have the part
that i need they go online
probably to rock auto they get the part
in and then i have to pay twice as much
as i would if i just go into
rockauto.com
so much easier just do that they're a
family company they've been serving auto
parts customers online
for 20 years they don't have all these
crazy gimmicks with pricing and it goes
up one day and down another day and all
it's just always reliably low prices
best for me most important thing
the website is simple enough even i can
navigate it even i i don't know i can
barely tell you the difference between
brands of cars
but even i can navigate this website
very useful especially these days
when the in-store shopping experience is
not exactly pleasant
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds
of manufacturers rockauto.com you go
there right now
you see all the parts available for your
car or truck
and then you write nulls canon wlas in
there how did you hear about usbox
so that they know that we sent you
the people who are openly calling for
the death of the president right now
on the internet which is a lot of people
should be arrested
and charged with sedition
sedition now some people say i tweeted
this yesterday they say
michael the first amendment it's a free
country you're allowed to be seditious
you're not you're not sedition
has never been protected by the first
amendment it has never been considered
to be protected by the first amendment
and today it is not protected by the
first amendment now we have to get a
little bit more specific it's not just
everyone
who tweets something stupid on the
internet that should be arrested and
charged with sedition
the the statutory definition is pretty
clear 18 us code
section 2384. according to the statutory
definition of sedition it is a crime for
two or more people within the
jurisdiction of the united states
to conspire to overthrow or destroy by
force the government of the united
states or to level war against them
to oppose by force the authority of the
united states government to prevent
hinder or delay
by force and execution of any law of the
united states or to take caesar
possessed by force
any property of the united states
contrary to the authority thereof
so now you might say under that
definition of sedition these people
calling for the death of the president
are not culpable well
some of them are because i bet you if
you were to look at the group of people
that is currently burning down american
cities in the name of
overthrowing the system of law
enforcement in the name of
taking federal properties and federal
courthouses
by force and you look at the group of
people who are calling for the death of
the president on the internet
and you made a venn diagram i bet that
that group in the middle
would be pretty significant just a hunch
i don't know maybe we'd need to
investigate and what i'm saying is
it is not conducive to our national
happiness
for people openly to call for the death
of our duly elected president
it is not conducive to our national
happiness to burn down american cities
that's not a grassroots movement that
is a highly organized radical subversive
insurrection and we shouldn't tolerate
it
certainly not in the name of the first
amendment which in no way
protects those sorts of things
you know right now it looks as though
coronavirus
is helping president trump in the polls
but why is that how on earth could it
help president trump in the polls
well you've got to look at joe biden and
the democrats because
i'm not just talking about the radical
democratic people on the streets who are
burning down the cities
i'm talking about all the way to the top
joe biden joe biden
even old good old scranton joe considers
trump supporters and conservatives to be
the dregs of society he recently said
this
at a human rights campaign fundraiser
take a listen
despite losing in the courts
and in the court of public opinion these
forces of intolerance
remain determined to undermine and roll
back the progress you all have made
this time they not you
have an ally in the white house this
time they
have an ally they're a small percentage
of the american people
virulent people some of them the dregs
of society
and instead of using the full mighty of
the executive branch
to secure justice dignity safety for all
the president uses the white house as a
literal
literal bully pulpit callously
callously exerting his power over those
who have little or none
those who have little or none he says of
the human rights campaign
one of the best funded organizations
in politics human rights campaign is the
ridiculously named group that radically
redefined marriage for the for the first
time in human history
radically redefined marriage they were
the ones behind that that's the equal
sign sticker
human rights campaign it's the group
that was found co-founded by this guy
named terry bean who has been indicted
for sexually abusing a minor
boy twice that them
no power at all somehow he's managed to
get off the hook though but they've got
they've got no power
they only managed to for the first time
in human history radically redefine
sexual difference out of marriage
because they have no power right of
course not
this is joe biden's deplorables moment
the mainstream media probably aren't
going to cover it but we'll cover it
we'll make we'll make sure this one goes
around he says that
trump supporters are the dregs of
society
and specifically what he's talking about
are christians
because he's speaking at this hrc
fundraiser
and he's saying look if you oppose
radically redefining
marriage away from including sexual
difference
if you are a christian or a jew or a
muslim but he's not going to mention
them
but if you're a if you're a christian
who opposes redefining marriage
you are the dregs of society you are you
are hopelessly bigoted
this of course is very religiously
intolerant of joe biden
but it does help to explain why below
the surface of these polls
president trump seems to be doing well
i'll give you an example
so covet appears to be helping trump in
the polls
uh there's only one poll that's that's
been put out since president trump
contracted the virus
this is a poll by john zogby strategies
and
it showed that uh right now biden is
only leading trump by two points 49-47
now compared to this older poll from
zogby which is july 8th
biden was leading trump by seven points
48-42
and then in august august 29th biden was
leading trump 48 to 42.
but then after trump had coronavirus
that lead shrunk dramatically such that
now
now they appear to be within two points
but there's a more interesting poll that
came out
there's a more interesting poll that
shows
it doesn't ask people what they think
about the presidential election
it asks people what they think their
neighbors
are thinking about the presidential
election and that distance
is giving trump a clear edge well why is
it because we live in a culture of fear
we live in a culture where you're not
allowed to say what you think
that poll may be the most important poll
that's come out in the past several
weeks
we'll dig into it but if you didn't get
enough politics last week this wednesday
october 7th
will be the vice presidential debate
between mike pence and kamala harris and
daley wires
matt walsh will be live reacting to the
debate as part of a special edition of
all access live
members join matt wednesday night at 8
45 pm eastern
5 45 pacific at dailywire.com to
chat live with him on the stream and in
the comments
if you're not part of dailywire already
join now as an all-access member get 20
off with code debate
so you can watch all of our upcoming
debate coverage live at dailywire.com
on apple tv or on the roku app and join
us on all access live
every night for online and live stream
discussions you also get
not one but two leftist years tumblers
with your membership
as well as early and sometimes exclusive
access to new daily wire products that
is this wednesday october 7th
at 8 45 eastern 5 45 pacific join us get
20 off your all access membership
with code debate when you sign up today
we'll be right back with a lot more
a new harvard harris survey shows that
a plurality of registered voters believe
that their neighbors
are voting for president trump that's
weird why would you ask people
how they think their neighbors are
voting well it's to avoid this
problem that we're hearing from people
who we we now
have been told that president trump is
the mango mussolini he's hitler he's
literally a nazi
and if you vote for him you're the scum
of the earth and you should be run out
of polite society
so when pollsters when strangers call
you and say who are you voting for
you might be a little more reticent to
give your answer
a way to give a little distance here is
to say hey who do you think your
neighbors are voting for
what's your sense of what's going on and
a plurality
according to this survey which was taken
september 22nd to the 24th of 1314
registered voters
a plurality 43 say that their neighbors
are going to vote for trump
then only 36 say their neighbors are
going to vote for biden
21 remain unsure
that tells you something
that tells you not only that they think
that president trump has a better shot
than joe biden it tells you that they
think that people are afraid of the
mainstream media
right because if the mainstream media
and the democratic party and the liberal
establishment generally
and big tech if they were not so
viciously
left-wing vindictively left-wing people
would be more likely to say yeah i'm
gonna
here's who i'm gonna vote for
but the fact that there's such a
discrepancy between who they say they're
going to vote for
who they say their neighbors are going
to vote for shows you that there is a
real sense
of repression there's a real sense of
having to keep your trump support quiet
this was true in 2016. it is certainly
true
today and it's because of joe biden's
religious language
it's because i mean the left generally
joe biden's just adopted it
this dregs of society the
the deplorables and the irredeemables
the bitter clingers
clinging to their guns and religion as
barack obama put it
it's because leftism is a totalizing
religion
it is it is different than christianity
it is in some ways an inversion
of christianity and
people get very very protective of their
religion
there are religious wars that are going
on not just
joe biden you know suing nuns for
instance promising to sue nuns
again if they don't give out abortion
drugs if he gets into the white house
not just bill de blasio saying he's
going to shut down
synagogues and churches andrew cuomo now
governor of new york
is threatening to shut down synagogues
if the jews don't get in line with his
covet policies
i have to say to the orthodox community
tomorrow
if you're not willing to live with these
rules
then i'm going to close the synagogues
i have had a 30-year relationship with
the orthodox community
it goes back to my father
i have a very close personal
relationship
with them this is the last thing
i want to do forget the politics
i don't care about that anymore
personally
i don't want to have this conversation
it's a difficult conversation
and you're right on the line of
government
uh intrusion on religion
so it's hard i didn't want to close down
000 bars put people out of work
you know it's hard it's hard you know
first of all listen to that
listen to that dichotomy there you got
the synagogues and you've got the bars
and he's saying yeah they're kind of the
same thing but they're not we obviously
have much
stronger protections in this country for
religion than we do for drinking and i'm
a guy who i enjoy going to bars
but for cuomo it's all the same because
really what they're talking about is a
protection of their religion
the religion of leftism the religion of
administrative government the religion
of rule by experts
the religion of we know what's better
for you than you do
he says look i wish i didn't have to do
this but i'm going to close down your
synagogues
if you don't take a knee if you don't do
what i tell you to do
on kovid what are we so afraid of if you
say to me right now
michael you can sit at home
and your chances of getting covet are
going to be way way lower
and let's say kovid were even much more
dangerous than it is
let's say that i could extend my life by
10 years
if i just stayed home and never went to
church again
or i could reduce my lifespan by 10
years
and go to church i would go to church
of course of course i would
because of the christian view of life
and i bet if you asked jews that which
if
you could either extend your life 10
years by never going to synagogue again
never celebrating the high holy days or
you could reduce your lifespan 10 years
but go to synagogue
i bet they would say they'd go to
synagogue i bet
the muslims would say they'd go to the
mosque
the left can't understand that because
they're making philosophical and
theological arguments and they're
pretending they're scientific arguments
but they're not you know science as we
think about it today
is a mode of material inquiry it's just
saying we're going to investigate these
physical phenomena
but what undergirds that is
philosophical and theological
i would rather go to church and this
even outside of the religious context
is true of a lot of people who you know
just would just be
more philosophical they would say look
i'm yeah maybe this life is the only
life we have but i'd rather go live it
than cower at home and fear
i'd rather go live my life and take a
risk and maybe reduce my lifespan
then not live my life and turn into a
couch potato
and cower and fear i'd rather show some
courage i'd rather show
some virtue these are competing
religions competing religious creeds you
might have seen the new religious creed
of the left
you might have seen it if you were
driving by you don't see a lot of joe
biden
on signs because no one's excited about
joe biden but there is a lawn sign that
the left has adopted
it's the we believe lawn sign we believe
which is
like in christianity you have the credo
which is i believe i believe in god the
father almighty
and in leftism you have we believe and
the sign says
we believe black lives matter no human
is illegal
love is love women's rights are human
rights science is real
water is life injustice anywhere is a
threat to justice everywhere
it's kind of weird why are you putting
all that on a sign what does that mean
most people probably would could agree
at least with the
individual slogans here but this is why
slogans are so dangerous so you've got
to look down a little more deeply at
what this means
and what it means is though it seems to
be affirmative and positive
it's actually purely negative we believe
black lives matter well what does black
lives matter mean black lives matter is
in a validly marxist organization
that seeks in public policy most
directly to abolish the police right
that's that's what we've seen
at all of these blm rallies that are
highly organized highly funded
have founders who admit that it's in a
validly marxist organization
so that's the first one abolish the
philosophical underpinnings of our
country and abolish the police
no human being is illegal what does that
mean it means erase national borders it
means there's no such thing as illegal
immigration everyone has a right to come
into the country
but only our country we don't have a
right to go into other people's
countries love is love what does that
mean that means abolish traditional
sexual morality because
only those awful christians and jews and
muslims would ever believe
that there is such a thing as a sexual
morality and there could be sexual
violations
only those drugs of society would
believe that so abolish that
women's rights are human rights that
means there is a patriarchy
we need to overthrow that patriarchy and
ultimately the way it was used when that
phrase became popular particularly
during second wave feminism
is we need to abolish the the normal
normality of the nuclear family
we need to get rid of that and break it
up and have all different sorts of kinds
of families
water is life this one fooled me this
one i had no idea what this was
water is life what kind of weird stuff
that so i googled it turns out that is
an
anti-fossil fuel slogan
it's a slogan by environmental people
who want us to
give up our entire energy system and
then
injustice anywhere is a threat to
justice everywhere now that
obviously isn't true you know
injustice in pakistan is is not a threat
to justice in the united states
except in as much as we live in a fallen
world and
and while there is sin in the world sin
and death will pervade the world but
we're not going to fix that through
politics anyway
so put that aside injustice anywhere is
a threat to justice everywhere what does
that mean
means abolish the whole damn system
justice right that's the end of
government as james madison famously
said
it's the whole point of the system is
justice
so if if the system is in any way unjust
we need to get rid of it and start over
that's a left-wing creed they just don't
recognize it as such
this point of science is real that's
that's part of a creed they just don't
recognize it as such
they don't they don't realize that when
they say
we want to live in fear we want to shut
down society
in perpetuity all we value
is our physical health whatever that
means such as it is
they don't realize that that cowardly
language does not speak for the rest of
us
that believe it or not there are people
out there who value courage
that there are people out there who are
willing to take risk
that there are people out there who
realize that there is risk inherent
in anything we do in life even sitting
at home
and we're going to take our chances and
pursue the good and do what we can
they don't realize that there's even
really an alternative
beyond the bigoted musings of the dregs
of society
they don't see the other side of that
speaking of black lives matter which is
you know the
first line on the sign black lives
matter is kind of the
it's the gateway into this whole idea of
what the founders would call
marxism speaking of black lives matter
there's a great
video going around right now the
daughter of an ambushed cop
just spoke at a blue lives matter event
this woman just spoke about risk and
courage and not being afraid because her
mother was ambushed on the job
and she was killed by a career criminal
at the age of 48.
this is genesis familia
her her mother was meosotis familia
take a listen my mom was a true patriot
and she loved this country and was proud
to be an american
the text of muslim familia was an
amazing
daughter to my ugly grandmother who she
took care of
an awesome and loving sister to all of
my uncles and aunts
and she was a fun aunt herself to my own
cousins
and most importantly she was a mom to me
and to my younger brother and sister who
i now have to be a mom to
and i race on my own
my mom like every other police officer
on the job who sacrifices so much time
from their friends
and their family to protect all new
yorkers
put our life on the line every day to
make new york city a better place
and she truly felt that
she was an amazing human being and she
was taken from me and those that loved
her
just for the blue uniform that she wore
heartbreaking stuff to listen to this
woman very uh
puts it all into perspective i suppose
particularly on this point of courage
the left they don't seem to understand
why
anyone would join up in the police why
anyone would enlist in the army
they seem to think it's crazy i mean
this this
really began in the modern era in the
1960s when cowardly university students
didn't want to serve their country
so they dodged the draft one of those
guys who dodged the draft became
president actually in the 1990s
one of those democrats they don't get it
why would you why would you do it their
only view of cops is that cops
just join the force so they can kill
black people right obviously i don't
think
i don't think this woman's mother was
out there because she hated black people
being black herself
but there is something higher believe it
or not maybe we've just got to show this
to our friends
on the left there is a higher calling
than just protecting your physical self
at all times and courage takes different
forms by the way there's there's one
issue i've got to touch on
a lot of people aren't covering it it's
a vatican scandal it's not a sex scandal
though people
people only ever focus on the sex
scandal which obviously was horrific it
came out in the 2000s but it mostly took
place
in the 70s and 80s and a little bit in
the 90s that was where the bulk of these
things took place
right after the spirit of the 1960s the
spirit of vatican ii whatever you want
to call it
spirit of 68 and
sure i mean those were horrific you can
read the pennsylvania grand jury report
it's really horrific
but very often those scandals distract
from scandals that are
ongoing at the vatican which is in
vatican finances which is at the vatican
bank
and sometimes the sex scandals are used
explicitly to cover those up
there was a case of of an australian
cardinal cardinal pell
who was accused of
of sexual abuse and the allegations
never made any sense they didn't add up
the timelines didn't
add up his relationship to the
individuals didn't add up
a lot of people didn't believe it and he
was convicted and then
this was overturned now it is coming out
that another cardinal cardinal batshu
it sounds like you sneezed cardinal
bachu the former head of the
congregation for the causes of saints
is now being investigated for
bribing the individuals in the cardinal
pell case
to accuse cardinal pell of sexual abuse
why would he do this because cardinal
pell
was trying to clean up the vatican bank
everyone who tries to clean up the
vatican bank everyone who tries to go
to the heart that the the still beating
heart of the corruption of the vatican
always winds up in trouble somehow
those forces those dark forces at the
vatican
somehow the bad guys in the vatican
always seem to get them
now this is a in a way it's the same
kind of courage but in a very different
realm
from someone say joining the police or
someone
enlisting in the military when you go
after corruption in the political
realm or in a or even especially in a
spiritual realm
you are opening yourself up to attack
you are opening yourself up
to big big trouble a lot of people when
they see that everyone who tries to
clean up the vatican bank gets
their lives ruined they would probably
say you know what let's lay off this one
for a while
maybe i don't need to go after this
that's not the right attitude to draw
that's not the right conclusion to draw
rather not the right attitude to have
the left would say so the left would say
let's just back away well of course the
mainstream media
these they're they're part of the
corruption of this liberal establishment
they are the corruption in many ways
only corrupt truly thoroughly corrupt
people
would discourage you meaning to take
away your courage
what does courage mean it means to have
heart to take heart from core
that is what corruption does
virtue tells you to have heart to be
encouraged to to
recognize christ says this in the
gospels right he says you'll have
troubles in this world you will have to
not not if you elect the right
politicians
they'll solve all the problems in this
world not if you just have the right
social policy
then all the problems will go away he
says no you will have
trouble in this world but take heart i
have overcome the world
that is the view that built our
civilization that is the view that will
forge your souls
that is the view that the president of
the united states is giving out to us
don't be afraid take heart
and for all those thoroughly corrupt
people
trying to discourage you tune them out
they're just another trouble you'll have
in this world but take heart
and don't be afraid that's our show i'm
michael knowles that's the michael
knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer robin fenderson hair and
makeup
nika geneva and production assistant
ryan love
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2020.
you know the matt wall show it's not
just another show about about politics i
think there are enough of those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen